wow
fam i wouldn't know whether to laugh or
cry family i'd stare at her in silence
because that's a threat but also a
compliment at the same time yeah
that mouth is mine now
i can't have you going back to your wife
[Music]
guys
girls what's going on brav you asked
and you received look at us white robes
white robes and easy tours
full effect courses
you guys you were complaining i couldn't
get any tickets
we couldn't get any tickets for june
21st find the link where is it at where
the link is not working has it sold out
so quickly that's record time that can't
be factual
we're big boys would you like big boys
in the game now we sold out in a couple
of hours it was satin light light and we
didn't realize anyone was going to be
vex about it you know so what we've done
guys we apologize we
apologize we apologize apologize yeah
but to make amends for you guys double
down we've doubled down yeah we've got
ourselves a bigger venue a bigger thing
a bigger tip slightly bigger
is about three times the size i'm just
saying though saturn just for you lot
yeah yeah okay so guys listen up here
come the dates hot and fast location
we're gonna do one more in london all
you northern man don't worry you're
coming up soon just wait soon come let's
get through this all right yeah man
london
shepherds bush empire facts
29th of september do not forget it bravo
29th 29th of september is where the
shubs will blow up we've warned you 29th
yeah now tickets tickets bro tickets for
you patreon and 02 priorities our o2
venue so we have to shout out the o2
priority are you o2 managed right now so
you've got double pre-sale now yeah yeah
double preset patreon 02.
cool pre-sale goes live
10 a.m
monday
6th of june general sale
wednesday
eighth of june 10 00 am as well
you man i know you were upset you missed
out last time and patreon scooped up all
the goodies this time we've held back
the vast majority for you man we're
looking after you man this time yeah so
don't say oh i can't find the tickets oh
i can't find the link because it's gonna
be it's gonna be there bro there's gonna
be plenty tickets just wait scoop that
scoop dab next week wednesday
10 a.m be ready at the starting line
yeah ma'am because the link will flow
and you'll need to hop on it immediately
set your alarms for nine
so you can snooze till 9 15 9 30 you
know because once it hits 9 59 there's
already a queue and that's not going to
be on me that's going to be on you yeah
you feel me so guys we did this for you
we wanted it to be a one show bonanza
test the water see how it goes so many
people were vexed i was getting calls
calls calls messages messages guys you
can't do this the general public is
going to be flipping
riots bro
excuse me there's going to be riots bro
yeah ma'am so we're like calm down calm
down we're humanitarians let's put on a
second show for these guys look after
you look after them yeah mom bigger
venue bigger venue bigger budget bigger
budget come on man you know the vibe so
guys states again places again
shepherds bush
empire
september the 29th is the live show
that's when it's going to pop up that's
when it's going to pop off but the
tickets the tickets itself
monday pre-sale
patreon
o2 priority 10 a.m
wednesday the 8th of june
9 59 you man better be in the queue
already
general admission sales goes live at 10
a.m we've told you the dates we've told
you the location
you better be there see you there guys
love love love
my nemo lover i actually hate that song
like sweetie i just [ __ ] spill why
why is that song coming to your head it
was you were on tick tock or whatever
i heard it
i heard it
i said i actually hate that song
i [ __ ] hate that song bro speaking of
we're live right we're going in it we're
moving yeah so we're shaking
um
speaking of i was thinking on your way
on my way here so i was listening to the
track it made me think what was the last
song you listened to before you got the
car today
oh i wasn't doing it i wasn't even
listening to music but i think the last
song i had on
was
um
i actually do know what it is i can't
flip him remember brother
um
i should be able to clock i think it was
sir he's got a new song i've seen it's
got a new song i've not heard it it's
called satisfaction okay so annoying bro
it's only like two minutes long but i'm
assuming it's juice i'm just banging so
slaps yeah he does especially when you
drop singles mmm facts his albums are
always bang but you have to dig for the
banging ones when you drop singles they
always slap i'm a list of sir in a
minute i was going through a phase when
i listened to sir we all were yeah we
were we were we were second 1920. yeah i
was listening as a [ __ ] artist wow
yeah yeah yeah
when he's that john redcorn song he's
got is my favorite ah that's a tune it's
a fantastic is deep that's a cheap and
it's literally based off king of the
hills yeah yeah i remember you telling
me you told me on the show yeah yeah
yeah yeah
bang
songs the track bro bro yeah um
any guys any guys anyway guys welcome
happy monday to you
we hope you are well um
yeah man things are things are going
well for us now man it is they are i
said it is they are they are going well
for us um and that's down to you guys
let's down to the patrons that's down to
you guys telling another friend to tell
a friend tell a friend and um yeah we're
eternally grateful and
this is the reason why we just keep
going and going and going you know keep
going and going and going guys
and uh yeah man we couldn't be more
grateful for you guys everything's going
well everything everybody's feeling
lavish we're meeting lots of people just
out on roads
um
i had she specifically asked me not to
say this story but i'm actually going to
say it um i was in
the corner shop near mine today
and um
some girl was like um
she's going behind the counter yeah she
was like oh um you look like one brother
that i watch online as well is it hmm
she was like yeah yeah
i said that's cool and then um
this one like can i have a bag please
she's like
she's packing my [ __ ] in there she was
like nah you know what you actually
really look like yeah and i was like
what do you want me to say run my
groceries
cool man
um and she was like yeah he does this
like a podcast and i was like okay
you're talking to yourself in love yeah
yeah you just keep embellishing on this
[ __ ] guy that i apparently look like
yeah yeah yeah and then she was like
yeah yeah oh it's really funny and i was
like okay and then she was like
is it you
every fiber of my being wanted to say no
yeah but i just couldn't be bothered
for the potential consequence because i
know what happens when i say yes i don't
know what happens when i say no i've
said no a few times and it happens
different way a few times i've got the
energy for this and i'm in a rush and i
was like yeah it is and then she said
fam she said is it really and i was like
yes fam she screamed she's on duty fam
she screamed to the top of her lungs no
she never screamed to the top of her
lungs
and i was like oh my i think that first
thing i think should have said no
oh no she never yeah she is she's
actually a bit peng as well no that's
red if it's a story but she just it's
just just for your imagination yeah
she's
and that's when she was like ah don't
say this on the thing i'll say it's calm
and then i thought i am going to say it
on the thing actually
um but anyway that was nice of her but
um so yeah we're getting opportunities
obviously to meet loads of people
recently
uh which is nice and do lots of cool
things and meet cool people so thank you
guys as always for riding with us um
also on top of that guys you already
know what you need to do so make sure
you do it new people come on every
single week who have been watching us
for ages and ages and say you know what
[ __ ] it finally i'm deciding to do this
i know all you man just got paid it's
the beginning of the month i know all of
you got paid guys so stop what you're
doing head on over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs
catch us every single thursday on there
catch up with two years worth of content
over there there's bits and bobs on over
there that people are just picking up
parts of the story yeah true you man
over here are listening and watching to
every other episode and you're always
wondering where's the even numbers yeah
why there's never any even numbers
they're all on patreon guys so there's
there's stuff that you men are hearing
us talk about on here that we may have
said over there there's a big community
over there chirps and things in the
comments over there everything's going
well guys so it's going to cost you
three pound a month 10p a day run the
peak
um and enjoy an extra episode every
single week guys ad-free yeah man
non-censored
unedited for the most part um
little bits of
pizzazz in there
but no cards a bit of flair yeah a
little bit of flair but no cuts over
there guys so yeah patreon.com four
situations
uh and make sure you head over there
right now
um
obviously guys if you guys are listening
on spotify which a lot of you guys are
apple podcasts google podcast
amazon music where wherever you guys
listen to your podcast please please
please leave a nice review guys give us
a nice star rating it does wonders for
us it does wonders for the show we
always want to keep growing and keep
doing better um we want to keep kind of
we want to help our families out here
[ __ ] that we want to do guys so please
head on over there um and leave us a
nice review and continue to listen make
sure you subscribe to the show make get
those auto downloads and whatnot um and
lastly guys if you are watching us on
youtube right now please like the video
if you like the video
subscribe to the channel
notification bell on we're dropping
content hot and fast and lastly chirps
18 in the comments it's non-negotiable
non-negotiable guys we've got live shows
now so when people are rocking up to
these live shows i expect you to know
one another exactly if you don't know
clearly your business will give you
about every opportunity to chirps things
in the comments you should be walking in
there holding hands hand in hand
in mine at the foyer area
[Laughter]
yeah guys that's it um
but i think that's it guys that's the
introduction for today yeah man so let's
head on over to flags and he's gonna
he's gonna hit us with some knowledge
and some some uh
some pop culture yeah man so um this
popped up on my phone not too long ago
so there's a 19 year old 19 year old
sparks age gap debate after proposing to
a 76 year old girlfriend have you read
have you seen this young brother yeah i
see the picture yeah yeah yeah obviously
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry i wasn't
thinking yeah yeah i saw that because i
didn't read the title i just saw some
pictures yeah
i mean i don't want me yeah she's
[ __ ] old
the thing is what she doesn't even look
good for 78
60 76 76 she doesn't look good for 76.
she looks like 86. i mean is there a
difference anymore i don't know is there
a difference what i'm saying is you if
like if you're that young proposing to a
76 year old woman like i want to see a
picture and be like fairy [ __ ] enough
yeah madonna yeah yeah i mean old but
yeah you're trying yeah you're trying
and i'm like a chair or something like
that yes
she looks [ __ ] old bro yeah yeah
she's got that old woman curly hair is
everything in it and some raincoat thing
i think i saw i only saw it for a brief
second i'm all right
let me let me see this thing hold on oh
no they're going it's flashing through
pictures and stuff
ah yeah let me see this yeah
this is just oh she actually is [ __ ]
old she looks like do you know who she
looks like in that picture she looks
like the old
um granddad from up
she does the old man from up she doesn't
love that old man from up she's old
brother she looks like she's from
eastenders
and he doesn't even look 19. he looks
15. bro this is all top what are we
doing navi topsy turvy bro wow
yeah man so how long has he dominating
with her does it say uh let me just read
the thing real quick hold on
so giuseppe19 took to tiktok on tuesday
to share to share news of his engagement
with followers despite the romantic
compilation video of photographs um of
the moment he got down on one knee not
all viewers congratulated the soon to be
married couple obviously
however it wasn't the way giuseppe
proposed that some followers had an
issue with but the fact that giuseppe's
fiance is 57 years older than him making
her 76 years old
someone commented guys just trying to
secure the bag i was gonna i was
literally saying she got cake never this
is actually very sexist of me because
he's the younger one and she's an odd
one it didn't even occur to me that he
might be looking for money it didn't
even occur to him
which is really bad because that's the
only thing that makes sense actually i
just thought he was twisted
the thing is i don't even understand how
that dynamic has come about like what is
apart from like a grandson grandma
scenario where are you meeting 76 year
olds on a frequent basis to start dating
have feelings fall in love and then
propose maybe he works in like a care
home he must do maybe he works at bingo
hall something you must yeah to be fair
something to be fair yeah he has to have
daily access to these old yachts
he has to she must have money she must
have money some wilting
and also like he looks young he does
look here so he he doesn't even look
like
cougar
young
for her from her perspective perspective
he looks like a [ __ ] kid yeah yeah
it's
both twisted it's grotesque he can't be
banging her
he can't be connie
if i'm i'm just going to be open to her
yeah and be like look
big man if you want me to bang you you
need to promise me money none of this
whole promise me molly yeah i need it
right yeah none of this oh let's get
married and then i hope you might leave
me in your will because i'm gonna
pretend to love you no no no no if you
want this dick
put it in the will now
and need to see it i need to see it you
don't need it you can't take it with you
because i'm not i'm not you know what
you look like that's the thing as well
you know what you looked like past tense
and you know you look like that now yeah
let's not pretend that this is love
let's not play silly [ __ ] games yeah
because it's definitely not lost
you look yuck [ __ ] man i just don't
understand that that that kind of
dynamic what kind of money do you need
to do that if you were him if i was 19
and she was 76
i am but you need to see this out until
she dies she could be going for another
30 years i [ __ ] hope not she could be
obviously he hopes not yeah
marriage [ __ ] um
i need to be
getting at least
seven figures
from the will seven figures yeah to be
19 bro oh right yeah i would assume
seven that's like a mill yeah minimum
yeah so you um
okay
do you also need lavish life now
um because okay we're talking
potentially
30 years so you're basically saying you
go through 30 years of banging an old
woman for one million pounds
at the end of the day
i was thinking about a lump sum fee
right now
yeah yeah
um [ __ ] oh
um it would have to be
upwards of 10 m's all right so
10 m's if i'm being realistic with
myself yeah because if i don't get the p
until she passes away
i would have to make
i don't know i'd have to make some
sacrifices and the thing is he's going
to be down near 50 himself by the time
she passes away yeah he's going to miss
out on so much being married to this old
slag
he's going to be cleaning up after on
all sorts she'll be able to get her bed
properly soon yeah brav she's gonna have
room in toward arthritis he's gonna be
massaging the gown in her foot oh man
what is long it is very long it's just
it's literally just long it is very very
very long i just don't understand she's
just gonna be chatting [ __ ]
talking about pastimes i'm talking about
corrie in that conversation is going to
be so boring what are we going to talk
about there's no there's no middle
ground she can't possibly be interested
in what he has to say and vice versa
i'm not even interested in what 19 year
olds have to say
facts i'm literally not interested
i'm literally not interested in facts
the whole thing is done buff but yeah
hopefully he's trying to secure the bag
i don't know why he put it on tick tock
maybe he's just trying to go viral he's
going to dump her tomorrow i don't know
what he's thinking it's probably his
nana they're taking the piss something
something needs to be going on bro but
yeah um
speaking of tick tock
trash news is just going around at the
minute by time this comes out would be a
week old but it's fine
um
have you seen the ting with this uh the
tik tock brother the mixed race guy
the what's his [ __ ] name he annoys me
brother he's back in the mix nah he
annoys me this guy's bait he because
it's him and his other boy that other
boy is annoying as well his name is uh
[ __ ]
like tikitoki satin okay hs ticket tokyo
whatever his name is okay um continue i
think i've seen separate continue so
he's got a boy called
he's got a white bredrin then they do
lives together and all this stuff okay
they're both they're both like two top
famous oh is it the
the
black girl thing yeah okay i saw it two
days ago yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so he
was on live with his boy yes yes yes
he said because before it started
spiraling i didn't see the live but i
think straight after the life happened i
saw someone repost on tick tock that
line i didn't see the live at all i just
saw that on social media yeah so he was
chatting to his boy and was just like oh
wow what are you doing are you going gym
so the white brother uh ed i think his
name is um
they're both knocking probably every
time
the whole time i've had tick tock in the
last what two years three two and a half
years every time they've popped up vexed
me oh really i've never seen them in my
life you're lucky
you're lucky both of them vex me um
anyway they they um
their main thing is they just like to
chat [ __ ] go gym and bang girls okay
which for their age group is fine yeah
yeah yeah yeah so i can see whatever
following yeah but the age group is fine
um so basically the white brother said
to my man the mixed race guy the tiki
tokyo brother
that's his name
the thing is i know it is it's just like
that's so wet yeah such a wet name
it seems like that and he did it he he
made that his name before he was yeah
and then he got too deep he went viral
before he knew what was going on can't
change it i can't change it now
i would still change it tikitaki um
so anyway my man went on there was like
oh
now i've been gym already i'm about to
link this thing
they said basically just said this
laying black girl and he was like oh
gang and then the white brothers are
sick yeah didn't say anything else
right my man was like yeah she's like
one of them we know one of them black
girls that's like looks white yeah
the white brother was like what does
that even mean
and the thing is this is how you know
it's a [ __ ] dumb thing to say because
the white brother says dumb [ __ ] [ __ ]
and even he was like
and he goes
how's that then bro yeah what do you
mean
what do you mean a black girl that looks
white
what are you saying
and then family doubled down and he just
basically was like oh like she just
doesn't look like your typical black
girl like she's not he said he's not
running around looking like diddy
when i heard that james
i was like are you [ __ ] joking on big
big life
these men don't care about repercussions
bro i couldn't believe it when i heard
that then so i see today on shea bro
that the the yacht that he's talking
about released the voice notes that he
sent her after and was like big he's in
her voice and said i don't know why
everyone's up in there fast
i was trying to say you're pink
because that can't be i said all these
black girls are just up in arms because
like they know their butters and he was
like i'm just going to say it black
girls are butters [ __ ] and you're not
you're lying
and then
he doesn't understand what he's saying
wrong doesn't he's gonna get he's not
even there but he's gonna he's done that
and man said obviously i'm a racist i'm
[ __ ] black and it's like
yeah but
you're
you're you're basic you're racist
because you're saying
you're paying because you're a black
male yeah but if you were the other yeah
if you would just happen to be born
female you're saying you won't be pegged
yeah he's it's long for him oh he's done
that it's long he's gonna get smacked up
yeah it's the it's the dreaded dumbest
thing i've seen is the dancing is saying
and like
it just made me because there's another
thing i wanted to to go on to say it in
a minute but like it just
certain times bro people
who have a following or whatever
just lose track of what they're saying
yeah
they lose track of what their intention
whether they're trying to be funny or
whatever because clearly homeboy doesn't
know what he's on about yeah he's just
chatting he's just fun he's just
chatting he's literally just chatting
and because he has an ego about it
because he's
quite famous or whatever mr tikitok he's
fam yeah the tiki talk he's got in his
blood
and he's he's continuing to double down
saying [ __ ] yeah and it's just like what
you said
you're obviously trying to say
you typically don't find black girls
attractive they're not your type you
find this girl attractive let's just
leave it there bro you don't even need
to say that but if that's how you feel
and that's what you want to say let's
just [ __ ] leave it there didn't need
to double down bro you double down on
this drug butting that was
like
i just don't even understand how he
could compare it to a black male but
what are you on about on about you're
just chatting and you're just chatting
[ __ ] and you're just like you're asking
to get smacked up by someone he is and
you're getting lost in it you could have
easily been like
to be fair i don't know i was just
saying [ __ ] trying to be funny and it
[ __ ] backfired i slipped up because
if you actually watch the live he's
clearly trying to be funny yeah
and then the bro when he realized his
boy wasn't laughing that's when he
because he did the drug betting he when
he said the drug reading he wasn't just
running in his mouth
he he said about um the black girl who
looks white
realized he didn't understand what he
was saying realized his boy didn't
understand what he was saying so he just
dropped a reference dropped a ting and
then laughed about it after
like you're all done at it
i'm not involved we can't be boys after
this
my face is now going to be on this life
because i don't want to be associated
with this chat it's long bro why and
you're just like
some people they just feel that they
need to say [ __ ] yeah and it's just not
on bro um
so yeah he will 100 get smacked up
um and then hopefully he just
either publicly apologizes or not but
just like fix up with what you're trying
to say bro he's done it it's like yeah
your preferences are your preferences
which is fine but just keep your [ __ ]
mouth shut like
black girls have a hard time as it is
yeah and
this is the thing as well this is i'm
looking out for myself yeah because when
black girls have a hard time i have a
hard time do you know what i'm saying
because he's a light skinned guy light
skinned guys have it hard enough so when
my skin guys are talking around all this
rubbish then black girls give me a hard
time yeah yeah and i don't need that i
don't need that because michael's a
length so be ling yeah and don't listen
to him and leave me out of it
i'm really not involved because then it
just it just rolls on because they have
it hard enough as it is so we don't need
to make life harder for them because
they don't sit there and have it
and then yeah they don't sit there and
have it and i i'm i'm i'm making
bedrooms with a lot of black girls
recently and this i don't need this
chat
i'm not on your side brother i'm not in
this side
so i just don't need it he [ __ ] up he
[ __ ] up massively
um
but that leads me on to because another
someone else who had a [ __ ] freudian
slip the other day was um jordan
peterson do you know jordan pisa jordan
pete is in the name rings about so he is
like a um
a clinical
psychologist basically okay and he is
like super famous at the minute because
he is very like kind of anti-woke
okay um and does a lot of lectures just
he's a very scientific person very
intelligent person okay um and he is
like he's like the main when people talk
about like uh gender pay gap stuff he is
like the main kind of guy that
publicly debates like the actual
statistics okay
so because he's a clinician
he only works on stats okay so he won't
entertain conversation about emotion
he won't under he won't entertain
anecdotal like evidence run me the stats
and he'll run you journals okay like
this study based in [ __ ] sweden shows
that this this this
say something so that's why i see what
he's famous for and he does a lot of
controversial talks but that like for
the point of the debate like he
typically wins the debates because like
he comes with facts yeah so
but he is because he's so anti-work and
stuff like that he
tweeted the other day and he's basically
he's always been a big proponent for
not encouraging um basically obesity
okay so people like when you know we
have people like lizzo yes and like i
remember there's a time a little while
ago lizzie must have said something
about like either being on a diet or
doing some exercise she physically got
flack because she's all about like
love the body you're in and body
empowerment and all that stuff as soon
as she says something about
oh i'm going to lose a little bit of
weight everyone thinks she's a sellout
and she's trying to be like one of these
normal what's happening with adele as
well so yeah yeah people actually given
and he's just and he's basically takes
the start of like what kind of [ __ ]
world are we living in when people say
they want to be healthier
and they're getting flack for it because
they are like the fat face like the
famous fat face or whatever it's like
let people be [ __ ] healthy yeah like
it's not healthy to be fat and he's
basically very much against the
promotion of obesity
excuse me
so he's very much against like
uh promoting obesity and all this stuff
and which i agree with i don't like when
people promote obesity like like when i
heard about like the same adulting and
the lizard thing i'm thinking of it's
not healthy bruh regardless if
if i saw someone who's overweight
regardless if i think they're laying or
not yeah it's a fact that it's not
healthy of course it's a physical fact
um and i hate when people just pretend
like it's not
um and the same thing a lot of it
stirred up around like the covetings
because obviously
like 99 of people who are like
hospitalized from kobe were obese okay
but there was never like any or we're in
a weird era now like where it's not okay
for to say you guys should try and lose
weight
it has to be like even like during
covered like no one was ever like guys
99 of these men are in here dying
they're all overweight you might need to
lose weight like if you're obese lose
some weight it's going to help you but
we're not allowed to do that because
that's quite quite fat shaming of course
yeah so you're not even allowed to say
be healthy you have to be like protect
yourself stay indoors all these things
there when you you should be allowed to
come out of that big man it's just not
healthy
like and because like such a large
uh part of the population especially in
like america um and here growing as well
are like obese
it's all about um
being more um
sensitive than honest so he's very much
against the like i'm not gonna belittle
truth
for
feelings it doesn't matter if it hurts
your feelings this is the fact okay i
only i only deal with stats okay i don't
want to hear i don't want to hear this
yeah [ __ ] your feelings yeah [ __ ] your
feelings these are the stats
we need to work on stats athena's are
irrelevant
so
he [ __ ] up the other day though
because he took that one step too far
okay i was waiting for that on twitter
and then posted i can't remember what
magazine it was but basically one like
plus size she was banging to be fair
plus-sized model was on the cover of
some magazine thing and he posted it and
was like
not beautiful
like and no amount i might actually be
able to find it because one of our boys
sent it to me give me a second let me at
least try it yeah yeah yeah so this is
the chick not she's not even that big
brother
i think it was is it sports illustrated
uh yes okay cool so
yeah she's just a yeah yeah
just a plus size not a woman yeah yeah
yeah
sorry not beautiful and no amount of
authoritarian tolerance is going to
change that
so
he's basically come out and said this
chick is not beautiful and
you you woke man can't force me to say
she's beautiful that's what you've
slipped up because that's got nothing to
do with weight that's got nothing to do
beauty is a subjective thing yeah just
because you don't find her beautiful
doesn't mean you get to come out and say
just because you're not in support of
obesity you can't come out and say
someone who's a bit overweight and say
this person
is not beautiful that's wild that's what
i'm saying that's obviously that's not
what he's trying to say yeah because he
he's just [ __ ] up he's got into the
routine of i'm a guy who says [ __ ]
and i'm a guy who speaks facts and all
these things and like
you're everyone's a human being you're
bound to [ __ ] up at some point yeah
massively you're bound to [ __ ] up and he
[ __ ] up but what he did same with the
tiki doggy brother he said double down
instead of being like you know what i
[ __ ] up what i meant to say is i don't
think we should be in support of an
unhealthy lifestyle and publishing
people who are overweight and um
insisting that this is a good way to
leave your live your life like this is a
sports illustrated magazine this is
about athletic sporty people i don't
think we should be putting obese people
on there saying this is a good way to
look because being a business is clearly
not good for you so i don't think we
should be promoting it that's what you
should have said because i know based on
a lot of stuff i've heard i know that's
how he feels but to come out and be like
this person's not beautiful
you're [ __ ] up yeah i'm sorry bro you
[ __ ] up but you need to what he did is
he basically got so much flack for it
and he then came out and was like you
know what twitter's too toxic i'm coming
off it and it's like in my opinion it's
like bro
nah you don't get to play that game yeah
you bitched out yeah you don't get to be
the guy who can say someone's not
beautiful and then when people are
giving you like slack for it you're like
nah this twit is too toxic yeah [ __ ]
that you're part of the toxicity yeah
you started this you started it yeah
you're gonna have to see it outro this
is the game this is where you make p
yeah like you're you're you make money
because you are known for this kind of
content so if you're going to put that
content out in the world you're going to
have to you're going to have to stay in
the pocket
you're going to have to yeah
this is your time to get smacked up a
little bit like you've just been out
here straight [ __ ] mike tyson and
everyone
settling people on this debate securing
people on that debate more money more
fame more money more fame more respect
oh these people are trying to cancel
more [ __ ] these people this is why i
believe more fame more pain more fame
and then when you say something that
even that your followers are like nah
you [ __ ] up then you're like nah [ __ ]
you
i don't want to talk to any of you man
it's like hey these people brought you
to the dance yeah you owe them respect
humanity
you [ __ ] up facts everyone [ __ ] up
and the worst thing you can do is like
i'm coming up to her don't talk to me
are you pussied out
you're a [ __ ] you [ __ ] now yeah he's
my north star so i love jordan pizza i
love jordan peterson but when i saw that
he po not only posted that but then was
like i'm coming on twitter like all you
man [ __ ] you i'm like
nah [ __ ] you
no actually [ __ ] you yeah actually [ __ ]
you because you did like
yeah you're [ __ ] up bro yeah and it's
okay to [ __ ] up you just need to own it
yeah yeah facts like this is twitter
people say dumb [ __ ] on twitter all the
time that's why i don't go on twitter
because you're encouraging twitter to
just say [ __ ]
you have to keep saying [ __ ] this is why
i don't i hardly tweet apart from
obviously our twitter i never tweet on
my personal yeah retweet and like bro
retweet i like it because you're you're
encouraged like
saying [ __ ] is the especially the
controversial [ __ ] is the currency on
there and it's like i'm not i'm not
going to have you force me to say [ __ ]
when i got [ __ ] to say because that's
when you find yourself in one of these
little situations bro there's some deep
hole yeah you find yourself in the hole
you gotta dig your way out yeah yeah
it's tough
it would be tough but yeah the fact that
he wasn't willing to dig out um really
pissed me off
i'm not [ __ ] surprised bro um
before we
because i know you've got like another
trash news right yeah before we do that
something we wanted to talk about which
we haven't haven't spoke about we
haven't haven't did you have and haven't
okay ted lasso
show
actually a [ __ ] show great as far
especially as far as light-hearted shows
go they're not really my back okay
typically okay shows of this nature that
are very light-hearted yeah yeah yeah
because even though they're swearing and
stuff like that it's very fluffy you
know what i mean
it's very fluffy like a scrambled egg
yeah it's very like i saw the christmas
episode yeah season two the other day
yeah and i was just like oh this is such
a shock cotton ball show yeah yeah yeah
um
and they were playing the [ __ ] thing
in mama's yard yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um that was sick to be fair but yeah
that it's a very fluffy show but [ __ ] me
is a good show it's a great watch it's
just such an easy watch bro it's a very
very [ __ ] good show and um
my main takeaway from ted i haven't
finished season two yet but my main
takeaway especially from season one yeah
was that
ted lasso he is the second fictional
character that has actually made me want
to be a better person
he was the first the flame hasherer from
team slayer i can't remember his name
he's dead now what's his name tengen
no no no
bro when i watched the demon slayer
movie yeah i was like [ __ ] this guy's
positive yeah yeah yeah he's so [ __ ]
positive very positive um same with ted
lasso he spins everything into
positivity bro everything into positive
bro ted lasso spins every single
scenario and he's so forgiving yes and
he gives so much chances to people and
he just wants everyone to be the best
version of themselves and
even at his own demise he's willing to
give his everything to like for people
to be better
and i'm like wow you're a good guy bro
the first time when when he landed in
the uk and he went to his first match
everyone scouted at him wanker wanker
what i would crumble oh i'm walking off
that could never be me can't pay me
enough of this this is abuse this that's
actual verbal abuse on a multiple scale
well and he goes into his local pub to
get a shepherd's pie and these might
call you wanker your [ __ ] wanker piss
off back home wow he's like bro just
came for a job fam
this is not it's not my fault this is it
it's not my fault she hired me where are
you up to on season two do you remember
the last thing the christmas episode was
the last one okay there it
you get to see what guam with ted yeah
you get to see wildwoman afterwards i
don't know why he is the way he is yeah
yeah yeah yeah fair play i've got little
tidbits about like obviously he
mentioned like playing darts with his
dad every sunday
that was a good that was a good scene he
was really good that was a really good
scene i think another powerful scene was
um when he was when he was uh chucking
it to jamie i think it was yeah jamie in
the first season about this is practice
man this is practice yes yes yes not the
game not the game you love not the game
you die
jokes i said this is practice
and you're not even willing he that's
the first time i've seen him
yeah
so sorry sorry to cut you off jamie for
those who don't even know like obviously
we've just been literally talking about
ted laser for those who don't even know
about the actual show so ted lasso is
about um an american geezer that's left
america to come to the uk to coach uh
what's the premier league football
premier league football team the team is
what would fc not what that's rich
richmond fc yeah richmond fc but
obviously he knows [ __ ] all about
football he coached american football in
the uk came to the uk um in america
sorry yeah america sorry he came to the
uk with um he's second coach beard beard
is a jokes guy yeah yeah straight to the
point yeah he is um and then yeah he's
just trying to find his [ __ ] feet and
everyone is pissing him off yeah but he
spins everything with positive spins
everything into pissing everyone else
off as well yeah the team don't like him
the fans don't like him the manager
doesn't like him the only person that
likes him is beard yeah and he just has
to keep going just keep going his
[ __ ] wife doesn't like him his wife
doesn't like him
keeps going keeps going keeps going he's
such a good guy man tough um but yeah my
biggest takeaway was literally like you
know what after watching like
first half of season one
i sat down and i was like
i'm really disappointed in myself i
really think i should try harder to be
because i like to pride myself on being
an optimistic person but sometimes
recently man like the pessimism just
creeps in my head okay and i just moan
about [ __ ] okay and i want to be the
kind of person the thing is regardless
of how much i learned about my own life
is fine but i want
always want people
to
i always want to be a positive
experience in people's lives you want to
uplift them yeah i want to uplift people
like i want to leave a room and someone
be like feel better about themselves
because of me so i have a friend that's
very much like that called josh i think
i've told you before he's a fan of the
show as well and
shout out josh he's the most positive
[ __ ] guy
i don't know how he is in a dark room by
himself
but when he's around me yeah yeah he's
so polite so positive and he'll always
compliment you no matter what we went to
cinema to watch uh dr strange a few
weeks ago and he was already sitting
down in the screen uh when i came in so
as i've walked in i spot him
go to sit next to him as soon as i sat
down he was like bro you are casting a
mighty shadow over there shoulders are
looking wide like well done that will
make you feel good
safe
really really really really nice guy
generous guy casting a shadow over there
yeah casting a monster shadow i was like
[ __ ] oh thanks bro
i'm saying he's super positive and he
always makes people feel better about
this even in the small interactions that
have he has with people like in the
least amount of words possible like
he'll always
say because i always try to tell
everyone to have like a nice day if i've
had an interaction with them or like
thank you if they stopped me in the
street and stuff like that but yeah he
actually makes that person
like wow that guy's nice like he's
always super positive
and um yeah he made watching ted lasso
thinking [ __ ] i want to be more like
that yeah and um prime examples
obviously i won't get to details but
me and phu had had a situation
the other day we made an enemy
we made a [ __ ] enemy unintentionally
we tried our best to be nice yeah and
funny and stuff like that but basically
we just met someone who really didn't
like us yeah and
after going home after that uh
interaction i don't think i've started
ted lasso yet okay i think i might have
started that night okay
and i was really upset with myself
because after watching it i was thinking
i had a perfect opportunity to sit down
with this person and actually try and
spin the the narrative
and be like just listen to what they had
to say yeah
um instead of just basically them saying
you chat [ __ ] i don't like you and me
being like sorry i didn't mean to
i don't mean obviously we were like okay
cool like did me defend you sorry like
but after that because they were being
like a bit standoffish and to be honest
a bit rude
i was like [ __ ] this person and i just
walked off and like nine times out of
ten i know a lot of people do that but
after going home and i watched a bit ted
last was like ted wouldn't have done
that yeah he definitely wouldn't have
done that ted at least would have been
like he would have held all the bullets
he would have been like wow disarmed i
didn't know he felt that way yeah like
we've got five minutes like can we grab
a seat grab a coffee and that's like
let's hash it out let's hash it out i
want to understand where you're coming
from i want you to help me and yeah so i
don't make this a mistake again like i
had the opportunity to do that and it
didn't even enter my mind yeah i was
just like
[ __ ] it like i didn't mean to say
anything rude yeah like
[ __ ] it then if you don't like me then
you don't like me and and that's just i
try my best to be a nice guy and if you
don't see that then [ __ ] it and it is
what it is if that's how you want to
feel them be that way and it's like
that's fine nine times out of ten that
is fine but then i it made me realize
that mad if i had the opportunity to
like at least make someone else feel
better regardless if the whole thing
gets resolved or not yeah
i could at least left there thinking
that like at least he made an effort at
least he actually made an effort he
clearly does care at least he made an
effort and i didn't make any effort yeah
i don't really meet that many people
that don't like me as a person
um
just off the bat without ever meeting
them before so it was a weird experience
to go for obviously you went through it
as well yeah it was a weird experience
and to be honest i was a bit like
paralyzed yeah i was like yeah
i was paralyzed
it's weird to me someone is like who
basically before you ever met them
they're like go [ __ ] yourself basically
and you're like
wrong
[ __ ] okay that's a bit much i will then
yeah
so yeah anyway todd lasso and um
rengoku both of them make me want to be
better more positive person in any any
interaction i can have with someone i
want to be
a more positive uplifting person going
moving forward so that's what i've taken
away from ted last year so guys go watch
tad dissolves
it is really good watch there's two
seasons on there i've finished both
james is going to finish the second one
soon yeah apple tv is three for three
bro i'm three for three telling you
[ __ ] what did you do what's the
second one you watched
so it was c severance then c now ted
lesson i'm four now i've watched
severance
uh invasion
uh c fam c
is amazing it's good isn't it
really [ __ ] good wow caesar maybe
jason is a man c is amazing see the end
of season two he's banging his wife he's
just grunting he's just [ __ ] quite
scars on his back just grunt ham and i
was like that's a that's that's a [ __ ]
jason my mom is that big oh
oh such a good one yeah c is great i'm
looking forward to season three oh same
hopefully there is one soon yeah
what's up guys let's take a very very
very very very brief break to small
break small tiny little break to see
some love on our boys over at manscapes
guys so we all know father's day is
literally around the corner around the
bend round the bend and manskipped is
specifically designed with father's day
in mind and the performance package 4.0
is here just in time for your popsy's
special day thanks inside this package
he's gonna find their lawnmower 4.0
trimmer thanks weed whacker ear and nose
hair trimmer
crop preserver ball deodorant crop
reviver toner performance boxer briefs
and
a travel bag thanks all of these things
guys have lavish we've tried them
multiple times ourselves we love the
boxes we love the ball toner we love the
cool breezy feel it gives them my nut
sack
um obviously the lawnmower 4.0 goes
without saying yeah
these man tried to tell me before like
oh when we first started doing this
research chat about r um finally you can
have a thing that's like just for your
balls you don't need to do anything
above like neck sometimes fran if i've
got a little
a little grizzle just it's the best one
i have yeah yeah so i'm gonna use it
it's literally the best one i have i'm
gonna [ __ ] use it i don't care if
it's just my balls
one for the balls yeah i've got a couple
of them so i'll just use it all over
yeah
sometimes it is i might need a lineup
i'm not even gonna cap oh this thing
here
i cleaned up this line all the time
there you go every time it comes out
there you go so guys
without any further ado you need to stop
right now go over to manscape.com and
use the code sng sierra november golf to
earn yourself 20 off
plus free shipping worldwide for
father's day that's around the corner
treat your balls right your dad's ball's
right he deserves it
um and guys let's get back to the
episode from there wow really really
good good right what we got
um a quick trashy trash um i'm just
trying to find which one it was
two seconds
there we go so this one
this one got sent to i think me slash us
multiple uh multiple times okay so you
might you may have seen this is like a
couple weeks old now but especially by
the time this comes up so husband leaves
wife of 10 years for ukrainian refugee
10 days after she arrived at their
family home
seen it
what fam seen it what he
he must have just need a new puss
he wasn't happy bro what he clearly
first out he took it literally first out
he [ __ ] took he he saw i'm not
defending him by the way i'm just having
fun with it before people get offended
i'm just having some fun with you
he was tired of the daily abuse
do you know what i mean he hasn't like
but he didn't know he was dealing with
that until he saw something fresh until
someone was actually so grateful yeah
just to let them in his yard yeah and he
thought wow this is what life this grass
is actually green
he sent her a tenner and said oh do you
want to go
exploring like he's 50 quid for the day
and she was like wow thank you so much
and he's thinking
oh
my [ __ ] snatches that money out of my
hand
my wife snatches it 50 is that it yeah
she says run me double that yeah she
wants me to
she wants me to have more free time but
she wants me to have more money she
doesn't want me to work longer he says i
can't win with her i can't balance this
life you know what ting from ukraine is
just grateful to be alive bro and i want
that that's fresh blood yeah i need that
fresh invigorated blood she's happy to
be alive he needs
he's
he's actually a narcissist because he
needs someone to boost his ego he needs
someone to boost him up yeah and his
wife's not doing that yeah his wife's
sick and tired for years sick and tired
of him yeah [ __ ] debbie why would she
envy oh so yeah
ten days in he said enough is enough
enough is enough japanese jesus
yeah she's so grateful and she's so
grateful hey let me read this thing real
quick so tiny tony garnet left his
partner of 10 years just 10 days after
meeting sophia
after sofia sorry arrived as a refugee
in the home in bradford sofia 22 had
fled ukraine city of la vie
and accepted tony's offer on social
media to host ukrainian refugees after
you sign up to the government's home
scheme props
sick tony sophia quickly developed a
connection and while his daughters also
took a liking to her his partner of 10
years felt the complete opposite shock
course she did shock
shock
things came to a head after an explosive
route between the two ladies had
sorry things came to her head after an
explosive route between the two ladies
had left sophia in tears and she's no
longer felt like she could live in the
same residence as lorna
tony commented something inside me
clicked
he would go and tell his wife if she's
going i'm going
can you imagine
can you let's roll let's roll reverse
this [ __ ] all right who am i and who
are you
i'm going to say no i'm i'm flipping it
to say like
it's it's roll reverse and then the
girls come to the yard oh
and um
sorry guys come to the yard sorry
you're
you're the miss you're the husband of
the missus
yeah yeah yeah we'll still call you
james cool
we'll still call you james [ __ ] i'll
give you a little bit
so lorna your missus has just brought
jamal in from ukraine it's always jamal
in it just brought jamal in from ukraine
you don't know how i don't know where
yeah yeah your kids love him
your kids [ __ ] they're hee-hee-ha-ha
all the time yeah people backs for days
but that you're just there when i say
for watching you're on the show for
watching tv about your side eye and
everything because you're vex yeah
your wife's saying our dinner's ready
everyone's come through he's he's she's
made a plate for jamal yeah and he's in
my seat he's in your seat ahead of the
table she just slaps your food on us on
the side while you're watching tv and it
just wobbles enjoy that peas just
falling on the table i can enjoy that
scum
you [ __ ] scum
you get vexed right after dinner let me
munch this food first because i don't
like to talk on an empty stomach yeah
yeah let me chow down the steak and
chips yeah the peas on the side us on
the floor yeah before i start losing i
already know she overcooked it yeah on
purpose on purpose well here's the
perfect meal you're ready your medium
rare garlic butter on the top you're
sort of a [ __ ] but yeah
right to a crisp yeah tough tough you're
chewing it for time yeah yeah are you
like say less let me finish watching
countdown yeah and then i'll come chat
to you man
boom boom boom you finish your munch now
kids go upstairs you're like
babes lorna i don't and jamal's out of
the room at this point he's playing with
the kids upstairs
on a non-sexual thing obviously yeah
he's on the oculus rift
he's playing with the kids upstairs just
keeping them company yeah yeah they're
happy to be about
babes
what just wag one because i don't
understand ever since jamal's been here
these past 10 days you've been acting
different yeah you've been [ __ ]
acting different pussy's fluttered
talk to me
say this tell me what one
all right i'll play norna now you're jp
all right cool so i've already said that
yeah alright so say let's you answer
wagon what's going on
james honey i'm not gonna lie to you
i'm not gonna lie to you
when jamal came in when he came through
it was all yeah
you're already better i'm already seated
i can't even look you in the eye yeah go
on go when jamal came in yeah he just
seemed and looked very appreciative of
everything i did for him obviously i'm
the one that signed up for this housing
team yeah yeah i'm the one that put all
these recommendations through i'm the
one that got him close i'm the one
that's feeding him i'm the one that's
doing this and doing that and he's so
appreciative and i do all of that for
you and i don't even get a [ __ ] thank
you
what do you expect from me
i've not had this in years sam i expect
mutual [ __ ] respect
i expect mutual [ __ ] respect is what
i expect
all this ah he does this for me
who does all these things for me you see
it away you you see the [ __ ] way he
gallops up the stairs yeah
do you think that's for nothing or do
you think that's because he just had the
the most lavish stake of his life
answer if you say you start i'll tell
you what i'll tell you what you're
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you started this sentence off with i'm
not gonna lie to you yeah so carry keep
that same energy yeah what's my saying
the exact same as his sake answer me
with your [ __ ] chest you dirty little
[ __ ] was my steak like jamal steak i
know how you like your steak you like
your steak a bit over over the edge
that's the reason that's the reason why
i tried to do it to your liking you're a
[ __ ] liar okay okay okay okay you're
actually a liar okay okay i'm going to
keep the same energy
lighting
all right my bad i lied yeah yeah i
cooked your steak last of course i was
cooking the kid's steak first obviously
jamal was in there as well helping me
out so after i cooked tomato cooked
tears i was cooking yours but whilst i
was like setting the table talking to
the kids i left it on for too long of
course you did
i apologize you didn't even rest it you
didn't even rest it because it was
taking too long and i knew you were
hungry you were going to kick off say
let's say let's see it was past your
dinner time i don't know i know what you
get like when it's 10 minutes past the
dinner time oh
you
you're getting ready don't do this don't
you dare you get [ __ ] high racking
dead so you're telling me you burnt my
[ __ ] steak and then you gave it to me
non-rested
because
of how i act
i know what you're like darling don't
you dare you're actually wow you're
actually guessing me
you're saying you're the way you you
saying you mistreated my dinner because
of fear of the way i would react if i
didn't get my dinner on time that's
facts it's facts [ __ ] is it facts
facts what do i do what do i do if my
dinner's late because i'm so such a
[ __ ] authoritarian beast i'm a
tyrannical monster apparently i act up
because my dinners are late you don't
get aggressive but you get moody and i
just don't have time for that we've got
guests in the yard wow
jamal's up in the yard it's actually
[ __ ] crazy
yeah tell them to come outside tomorrow
calm down please real quick
yo jimana yeah yo what oh no he's that's
not gonna say well i got anything yeah
i'll just speak normally then
hi hi james what's up what do you need
get checked out
excuse me sorry brother i know think i
know you've been through a lot but right
now this is okay the only way i can
explain to you is i feel like i'm in
ukraine
does that make sense
in my own yard
i feel like i'm in ukraine and this
[ __ ] is putin
and as far as i can tell you're
catalyzing the whole thing and i just
want to have the best marriage possible
and the way her cheeks are looking rosie
and that you're not helping the
situation but it's not your fault you're
very polite
but you're catalyzing
the scenario here so with with due
respect i'm gonna need you to get your
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
i hear what you're saying james but with
all due respect i have to speak to lorna
about this because she signed it shut up
shut up shut the [ __ ] show up again shut
the [ __ ] up i'll break your [ __ ] shut
the [ __ ] up she sucks she signed the
papers so it's all down to her i don't
give a [ __ ] what you say shut up and let
me speak to lorna
hold on shut up
what's up babe imagine babe hey say that
what's up babe
um your husband's saying that he wants
me to leave the yard
because he's feeling some type of way he
says he feels like he's in ukraine like
he's gone through hardship because he
had a well done steak
i know what i've been through don't
speak shut the [ __ ] up i'm speaking to
lorna right now i know what i've been
through and i can i can understand why
your
husband the weight feels good
but
forgive me
for being
appreciative for what you've done for me
lorna do you understand
big man shut up no no no no no no no no
no
no
i'm still talking to a lot
so you're
the dandruff of your busted head you
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you point that dirty
little finger at me again so
as i was saying lorna he said he wants
me to be out the yard
what do you say
babes trust me pick your next words
wisely
say i'm lorna now yeah say he's gone i'm
gone say less
if he's going james yeah i'm going bye
then
you think this is a dramatic statement
get your [ __ ] [ __ ] and go
oh i'm gone the yard's patterned the
kids are staying here the kids aren't
staying anywhere are you kids
oh staying here are you reporting you
actually want to take it to college
no kids yeah okay yeah say that sales
i will get violent for one
that's all this this back and forth ends
now listen lorna jamal youth human
[ __ ]
yeah daughters get the [ __ ] upstairs i'm
not even gonna i'm not entertaining none
of this now listen
you can leave with homeboy yeah i
promise you that now the youths
you think you actually think in a court
of law the youths are going to side with
you
when you're
taking the side of a brother that just
landed in the west today or a few days
ago
you don't even have a yard on your head
homeboy doesn't even have a passport
brother
big man ting i want the best future mom
i really [ __ ] do but you crossed the
line today and there's no coming back
so good luck take your [ __ ] go back to
kiev or wherever the [ __ ] you man are
gonna go because you weren't last here
you weren't last here you're gonna she's
gonna take you to a she's gonna do the
same [ __ ] you're gonna [ __ ] do she's
gonna complain about me to the group
chat she's gonna say everything
her girls are gonna talk her back into a
storm
they're gonna lift her up you may not
understand what i'm trying to say but
basically what i'm saying is this will
last 36 hours
she's going to [ __ ] you
she's going to cry she's going to slag
me off to you to the point where you
can't even hear it anymore she's going
to slag me off to her bedrooms who are
gonna slag me off as well because
they're all stupid little pricks
and then
when her belly starts rumbling
and she hasn't had her nails done and
she realizes
you can't provide anything because
you're not allowed to work
yeah
and you need someone else to to find you
a yard yeah
she will help you sign some more papers
to find you another yard and she'll say
once you get settled she'll come and
find you and then she'll knock on this
door
i'm lorna again
go on
james yeah don't you [ __ ] worry about
that
i've got the yard patterned you haven't
i've i'm telling you james you don't
know why you don't know what i've got in
my account don't i don't even give a
[ __ ] hold on hold on i'm i'm speaking
actually i'm speaking
you take your way out the door you don't
even know what i've got on my account
sidebar kids are running down the stairs
now daddy yeah we want to go with uncle
jamal we want to go with you
you would fight everything i'll say
uncle john was the prisoner of war i
said it
was a prisoner of war
i said it get out every man get out i'm
not entertaining this anymore because i
will start breaking jaws
gender fluid jaws
because you might not literally i've
never been so pissed off in my life get
the [ __ ] out bro
and i'm not going to do with this hoe
did yeah you won't find me on shea
butter talking about man of something
left for dickheading no
this stays under this yard yeah brother
good luck
good luck
oh bro i really felt the burden of that
i know you did i really felt like a
[ __ ] bird
shut the [ __ ] up
in real life i swear to god i would have
knocked homeboy the [ __ ] out
hilarious that's
wild to me family
stuff like that can't happen it doesn't
make sense it just doesn't make sense
wow
after 10 days she was like [ __ ] it if
he's gone i'm gone
be gone
it just doesn't make sense my girl could
never turn around and say that to me
after 10 years
if he's going i'm going we've got kids
together you've just met homeboy it's
not even been two weeks you've lost your
head and that's fine
i would never i would oh bro i i could
never like literally
sometimes i do think i'm a sociopath
because i do get to a point where i
promise that you know this whole like
you don't know what i got in my account
you didn't i would have switched off by
then yeah i literally would have my
emotions i have like a weird ability
that once i'm done yeah
whatever you say i don't care kind of oh
once it got to that point as soon as i
i'm adamant that she's leaving and then
she's even saying in terms of like oh
you don't know what i've got in my
account i'm gonna patent this the kids
are
emotionally blocked and i'm just are you
probably be talking to a dead body
basically
an emotionless shell you'll be thinking
you're i'll say you're wasting your
breath
you're wasting your dirty scummy breath
brother
your halitosis white tongue having
breath brav leave if you're leaving i
don't understand what this conversation
is oh my goodness understand what's
happening you're still talking to no one
i don't get it just leave you said if
he's going i'm going he's going so go
why i'm
you really got me in there and then just
expected me to just carry on
[Laughter]
yes
that's hilarious man said shut the [ __ ]
up i'm talking to lorna oh my god i
would have broken someone's arm
that's actually wild bro
yeah i'm cool if i'm all for this
refugee scheme but stuff like that can't
run yeah it can't it can't it can't it
can't that's that's
that's uncalled for wow
yeah
that's hilarious cool have we got ig
questions of course we've got ig
questions i'm excited let's do it
so guys
last week we asked you what's the most
you've done for a girl that's not your
girl
and as per usual guys
responses were
juicy
cool
picked her up from a beach day and ended
up chaperoning her and the guy she
brought with her
what
drove her three hours to uni even paid
congestion charge and got a cheers bro
thumbs up fam
some man do some [ __ ]
these are going to annoy me they will
they will annoy me because man
and on this one as well
because a lot of the mandem didn't reply
some gal wrote on the mandem's behalf
about what i've done for them
so be prepared
so this is one of them he did all of my
coursework as well as his own i was
relaxing
[Laughter]
the emphasis on that relaxing she's a
prick a prick
helped her plan a birthday party for a
chick i was talking so let me start
again i helped her plan a birthday party
for a chick i was in talking stages with
i dropped two hundred dollars
talking stages brav two hundred dollars
huh
really was a whole dad
going to her son's football games and
[ __ ]
and it wasn't even his girl wasn't even
his girl [ __ ] idiot bruv
he used to pick me up from work at 1am
buy me food and drop me home he never
missed i didn't even hug him
but the fact that like it's concerning
that the
these women would agree to this
that they will just utilize this they
will use an abuse to their liking when
they're done with you they're done with
you
and that's just a fact and the thing is
as well is that they don't mind when you
come to your senses even yeah which
makes it worse
oh he's wired up now i'm on to the next
one yeah literally i'm going to the next
brother fam he's just like oh you do
realize i've been picking you up at one
o'clock in the morning for six months
like you won't even hug me like what the
[ __ ] are you doing that's your business
that you took six months to realize this
[ __ ] you and your hugs [ __ ] you and your
petrol yeah what are that big man no one
asked you to pick me
you've been [ __ ] doing it you've been
doing it for months yeah it's your
business if now you've wised up [ __ ] off
then
or am i going to see you tomorrow you
choose that's what i thought
[ __ ] idiot i'd have to i'd have to
pop her nose
i'd want to shake her james
i couldn't be in that environment i want
to shake her
i would never do [ __ ] like that for a
girl not my girl bro facts i don't i'm
trying to think is there anything
you definitely done something i don't
know what it is probably
i probably have right off the top
done something for a girl that's not my
girl
uh it'll probably come to me let me run
through these but oh yeah keep going
i've already i already know one that
you've done oh is it yeah say it say it
now oh okay
when um
the ting after this is after
uh you'd already slept with like a year
after the not chick that freed up two
bags to a man that wasn't her man yeah
yeah
well i remember i came to visit you in
manchester
and you were like oh i'm knackered or
something
and i was a while ago one of you and
then you you were on the phone to her
for like two and a half hours i don't
remember that the night before okay when
she told you about that yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and i was like i'll swear like so what's
going on yeah and you were like oh i'm
just i was consoling
yeah
what i remember what are you talking
about remember that was that was a while
ago yeah i was like what are you on
about
[Music]
i couldn't believe it i couldn't [ __ ]
believe it wow i forgot i forgot about
that period yeah um cool put up with all
of her eight personalities oh jesus
christ haven't we all
he went to my church it wasn't even an
english-speaking church and he wasn't
even christian
i bet bear man i've done stuff like that
oh right i remember i was dating a girl
this she actually was my guy at the time
but her parents were [ __ ] hella
christian and i went to their house for
dinner and she said gonna warn you now
there's no way i can get away with
telling my dad that you're not a
christian i'll swear so we're gonna say
grace at the table okay just do it and i
said what if you ask me to say grace and
she's like that might happen
and if it does i'll take over for you yo
my blood
i told her straight you better hope you
don't ask me to say grace you better
[ __ ] hope this is a joke tip this is
a joke thing
this is some [ __ ] i'll throw you
straight under the bus i don't care rags
i said grace what's that
family oh he'd probably shank you
probably
probably get across and anoint it and
start throwing it on you bro what's that
he said james can you say grace
grace
can you say grace of course great grace
yeah well god what do you understand
what's the joke
yo
oh
he had a temper on him as well he would
have gone [ __ ] ape [ __ ] he would have
beaten you
[ __ ] you know that's hilarious race
right guys
ah held her coat while she was
fangirling over her crush oh
for [ __ ] sake booked the four seasons
for a night she cancelled last minute
i check forces is like just under a bag
but i know the four seasons is it is
extremely expensive roughly around a bag
at night she cancelled last night a
minute
to be fair now i'm thinking about it
there is things i've done for a girl i
haven't done it but there's like
i've symptomed for a girl before you
already know who it was van store
fans thought chelsea yeah yeah she used
to cancel on me last minute days in a
row yeah days in a row
it was painful for her yeah it was fine
i remember
wow
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're like oh
do you want to go cinema yeah yeah i'm
out here
cross-referencing times yeah yeah yeah
how are we getting over there i'm
willing to pay for taxi get into the
fam
come was if the date's at seven i'll
message her at six like are you still
down or do you want me to pick you up
but this time one here for her
i'm thinking oh maybe she's like caught
up at work we can get the view in after
yeah like a mug brav and then she'll
text me a dick at a clock oh sorry i
fell asleep or some [ __ ]
next day she'd be like oh do you want to
do something tomorrow gang of course i
do of course i do i love you
of course i do i love you don't ask me
rhetorical questions
i love you i don't wanna spend time with
you do you understand what i'm saying
for you darling do you understand
[ __ ] ask me dumb questions anymore
literally i [ __ ] love you of course i
remember the only time we actually did
something was walking around she was
looking for a new sofa side we just went
around furniture stores yeah that's all
we did you [ __ ] yeah i couldn't tell
any of you i literally couldn't tell any
of you no i remember coming home and
saying yeah lipstick
i couldn't tell you what actually
happened walked around dhs for company
nah [ __ ] that she used me bro she did
but i was gassed the [ __ ] i was used to
banging this thing i'd ever seen i know
[ __ ] that's him she was very painful
she was very very good-looking yeah yeah
wrote her entire
wrote her entire uni dissertation for
her to cut contact with me the day after
oh my god
how can you get swindled into writing
someone's dissertation that's 10 000 at
least min 10 000 words minimum min
it takes months bro she must have
promised him the world
i don't understand these things bruv
anyway continue
bought her her mum and her cat's
christmas presents
nah fam
[ __ ] this bro
my best friend paid for a six month gym
membership for a girl because she was
insecure about her weight she's happier
now and has since blocked him
fam
that was the same thing from the other
one he found his confidence and left me
she found her confidence and said safe
save for that six months i needed i
needed that
i'm getting good now primo dick now i'm
good now
[ __ ] you're a crutch
you're a [ __ ] crutch leave me alone
bought her flowers gifts and money for
petrol
she was driving her she was driving to
her girlfriend's house and giving her
the gifts
peak mad peek
mad
cancelled a job so i could
cancel the job so i could do some towel
work for some absolute worldy turns out
it was for our ugly friend
[Laughter]
this was me
some guy sent my mate a personalized
valentine's day video from lamar oh my
god
lamar been a long time saying you missed
me lamar
lamar bro
word gets around you shooting me lamar
step back don't try to kiss
what about now he's 50 50.
homeboy go i lamar
we had eyes on him that [ __ ] had eyes
on him but soon came
[Laughter]
that's hilarious
speaking on behalf of him he attended my
nan's funeral with me
wow i could never do such a thing
impossible i'm not going to anyone's
funeral for anyone period i'm not [ __ ]
that he flew me to trinidad he flew me
from trinidad to london for an
all-expense paid
vacation this is just a girl this is
just a girl
a girl he likes bro
what
i once had a guy drive seven hours to
come and see me i forgot to tell him i
was on my period
she did she [ __ ] i forgot to tell him i
bet she wasn't even on a period she
wasn't yeah she definitely wasn't i
forgot i forgot to tell her she just
didn't want to smash seven hours
that's a that's country to country
oh jesus christ i took care of her cat
for three months at my yard she never
spoke to me again after i gave it back
fab i can't deal with this bro i
literally can't deal with bro one night
stand a month later he sent me an
original song confessing his love for me
bought her three pairs of trainers only
for her to tell me she's dating a guy
she met she never met on xbox live
my days man some guy off tinder let some
guy off tinder let me use his netflix
for three years we never met
pique that is actually very very thing
is one yeah once you
netflix that's understand never is a
very hard thing to take back yeah
i mean unless you change your password
yeah it is you might just leave it yeah
if it's not inconvenienced in anyone
just leave it
i would take guys to wait sorry i would
take guys back to the apartment of a guy
i was in an open relationship with i
would also drive his car too oh [ __ ] off
piss take [ __ ] off this take
do these not have morals bro no they
don't
simple they don't have a conscience they
don't
they don't
he bought me a really expensive dog
online and he got scammed oh
he bought me special case cereal that
cost him seven pounds
[Laughter]
how special was this cereal special k
got seven pounds
i didn't know the isle of wight are
saying
what
because clusters is expensive and that's
like three pounds something yeah
clustered with a chocolate yeah three
sides three three feet
smaller yeah piss take seven [ __ ]
pounds on several cereal that's the most
heinous one of her
that is literally the worst one i've
heard it's seven pounds disgraceful
i took out a 3k loan for her
see that's a [ __ ] joke
wow
helped her break up with her ex only for
her to find a new man of course she
wasn't she was never going to go she was
never going to go with you
i knew a guy who bailed out girls from
oh sorry i knew a guy who bailed out the
girl's [ __ ] buddy from jail and let them
both crash at his place
that's impossible
they were just man's in bed and it was
banging in the other room
fresh out of jail they would have banged
fresh out oh he's not sleeping that
night
none of them are sleeping that night
you can't live like this man
she wanted to borrow money and said she
was gonna give it back to me in three
days it's been eight months
i promise you now
i would never in a million years lender
girl money
any girl i would never lend her money
it sounds outrageous i would just never
do it sounds outrageous i'll just never
do it i just find it the most perplexing
thing
i'll just give her give her the money i
suppose
yeah i'm not lending anyone money yeah
because i know i ain't getting better
especially if she thinks she's paying
yeah um yeah a butters girl i might lend
money
do i mean if we're boys and she's [ __ ]
ugly yeah i might lend a money any any
girl
that for even for an instant yeah thinks
that i might like her i promise you'll
not lend a number yeah you'll never get
that back of course not never for what
reason
he bought me a car and co-signed for
another one whilst i had a boyfriend
simp
drove two hours to pick up her grandma
from milton keynes only to see her lips
and her ex when we got back oh my
god bro
and these men is dread being a man as
well because you know they don't speak
up yeah yeah not one of these man them
spoke up
they just let it they're like
obviously the women one would [ __ ]
atrocious yeah
but these ones you just know the guy's
ego is not going to let him say
something a woman will pipe up
immediately
rags or eggs right he's not saying [ __ ]
got her friend a job came to find out it
was her fiance
[ __ ] sake i dumped him then he thought
he could win me back by tattooing my
name down the full length of his spine
fam what
that's what she said brother
the full length of his spine
my old best mate used to get given 400
pound plus worth of gifts on a weekly
basis of her friend's boyfriend
she must be banging
that's the first thing to post in my
head she must be banging
bro 400 a week a week in gifts also just
run me to four bills a week lie don't
buy me i don't want these gifts i don't
remember running four bills a week i'll
buy what i want to buy i'm gonna spend
on whatever the [ __ ] i wanna say yeah
gifts from her friend's boyfriend
brother
oh
that's nuts bro he's in a web of lies
man he's yes yes he's deep he can't he
can't leave out now yeah he has to keep
giving her the four bills he has to and
she just held that she's a terrible
friend oh right right drag drags
a guy bought my lunch every day for two
years and then got upset when i said we
were colleagues and not friends
[Laughter]
oh my god this man has spent over 30k on
gifts and dinners for me
never even held his hand and i never
will and she put life in my ass off
you don't have a picture though i'd want
to see her picture yeah
i want to know who that is this whole
laugh my [ __ ] thing
i don't like because i get messages
sometimes where girls will send me stuff
and then when they put laughing faces
afterwards yeah i want to be like [ __ ]
you i lie bro this this is fun for you
yeah and it's not okay yeah i need you
not to be caught out yeah in this weber
[ __ ] life yeah yeah yeah yeah i had a
girl message me a little while ago and
she was like our biggest it just
happened to me like um
her little like she caught him sneaking
she's like my sneaky link came around
and like whilst like banging me
he like whilst uh changing positions he
led back on his knees and fell off the
bed asked naked she was like [ __ ] ick
bear laughing faces
like joke man thing
like i'm supposed to join join in on
this i want to be in there so i can pull
it back up
i said this ain't fair man
poor [ __ ] guy oh my goodness
my friend was whipped over this girl he
still got with her and wait sorry he
still got with her after she dated our
other mate
that's like me being whipped off a ting
and then i just run through it you just
run through it and then when she's
inconsolable
you just you just pick up the pieces the
group chat will never be the same again
fam i swear to god i would lose so i
would get this and just square it in
your face for no reason
and i'll say i know you ain't going to
do [ __ ]
you've proven to me that you're a little
bit [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] you ain't going
to do something wow squeeze your face
squeeze it in your face
you just have electrolytes all in your
eyebrows
paid for her rent and living expenses
for 15 months and then she just ghosted
me
what what did these men expect to happen
i just i just don't 15 months brought us
so much money does she not rent and
expensive and expenses don't she work
what i don't understand
the [ __ ] man
amanda my stupid sometimes
[ __ ] stupid sometimes
stop 15
one day she just decided
boring boring okay
i've leveled up now yeah i don't even
need your money anymore bye fax she's
been saving
that's what she's been doing
man then pissed me off yeah same
he gave me money to bail out my ex from
jail we then picked him up and he
dropped us off at our hotel
exactly the same as the other one pretty
similar
vex
i left my i left my actual girlfriend in
bed to pick up a female friend's drunk
younger brother
he was whipped off this girl boy wow
clearly that's nuts no girl could ever
wing me while i'm in my bed with my girl
say my brother drunk not even she's
drunk babes please i know it's long but
my younger brother's pissed you can't
get home pick him up please for me for
me foo had for me sarah it's three a.m
but i know oh my no no no no these
people for me for me for me for me
i i'll owe you one suck your monthly
rabbit literally oh i thought i was
hanging the phone
my phone wouldn't ring anywhere we undo
that stuff so she's pissed her and her
brother pissed
my best friend's boyfriend banzai
i remember this one let me read it again
let me start slow
my best friend's boyfriend bandaged cuts
in her knees that were actual rug burns
from her [ __ ] someone else oh my god
wow imagine being on and he's just just
doing up your babe's knee just like oh
sorry babes what happened what happened
i just fell over fell over
yesterday she was getting absolutely raw
dogged on a rug
nah bro
what is happening check on your spouse's
you know i'm not gonna lie to you man
there's dodgy dealings
there's dodgy dealings everywhere
everywhere
told a girl's mum that she was with me
while she was in some other guy's yard
getting smashed
he just felt he was the full guy
he was just the full guy
this one sweetened me i think i put it
on the thing but i had to double back go
and go
she said i ate her [ __ ] so good she had
to tell my wife so she'd leave me
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow
fam i wouldn't know whether to laugh or
cry family i'd stare at her in silence
because that's a threat but also a
compliment at the same time yeah yeah
that mouth is mine now
i can't have you going back to your wife
[ __ ]
you
i need to tell you why you're
wrapped
wow oh god
i picked up her dad from the airport
possible i promise you now i'm not
picking her up from the airport dad her
[ __ ] anyone no
a man bought me an apartment that i
never even moved into
when i say to you man you man what the
[ __ ] are you doing
what women are gassing you like this i
have no idea bro this it
it vexes me when i see them and fold
like this yeah it literally doesn't make
sense and it's clear because like i said
to you earlier the mandem don't have the
balls to write it in the thing it's the
gal them that are out in them before
will the [ __ ] they've been you know
what the mandom know what they did they
know they [ __ ] up they just can't
admit they can't out it the women are
just happy to do it but they're laughing
faces afterwards oh the laughing remote
fam there's one i read i can't remember
and i didn't write it down but i posted
it on the thing she says something along
the lines of
i asked my
i asked my husband for money no no no no
i remember it now i remember i [ __ ]
remember
she said
i took
i sent my husband or my man pictures of
me at home
but i was away on holiday with my girls
i took those pictures last week i just
put a dance in the salsa emoji the salsa
thing
that thing threw me nah
the salsa
the yeah and the red dress
i couldn't believe what i read she said
she took those pictures last week i'm on
vacation b
salsa
[ __ ] you the odd
can we wrap the episode yeah it's done
it's done [ __ ] i'm back i'll be oh
[ __ ] that they're so conniving
very
very it's the
it's the audacity this is the absolute
men do dark [ __ ] yeah but they don't
glow
that's the thing they never will because
they're trying to keep a good thing
going
i see a thing the other day um some some
tick tock one brother was like
oh my girlfriend caught me cheating and
started hitting up uh
hitting up facebook or talking about i
don't know i can't believe um
what did she say what did you say was it
say
oh i can't believe he would embarrass me
like this i can't believe he'd go out
there and embarrass me said you're
embarrassing your damn self i didn't
tell anyone yeah facts i didn't even
tell you fat you're embarrassing your
damn sex
facts
men don't gloat about things they never
will they want a happy home happy wife
happy life that's it
if they have to lie to do something that
they want to do they're not proud of it
and they keep the man them stomped yeah
the man then they pattern the story
amongst the man and the man will say god
they don't laugh they don't yeah they're
they're the man
they know that they're not confirmed
they understand the assignment we got
you
this is intense yeah we [ __ ] got you
gal them would gloat
just this salsa thing through me james
got away with it through me
[Laughter]
have you no shame no if you're gonna do
dirt be embarrassed about it be shameful
about it it's not proud but we need to
do we need to everyone needs to do what
they need to do sometimes but [ __ ] man
why are you so happy about it
she doesn't love this is your man she
doesn't love him anyway guys
a good one as always thank you so much
for spending time with us um head on
over to
patreon.comgigs and catch up with us on
thursday
we love you very much always catch on
the next one love love
[Music]
you